i'm shannon bream i'm tom shaloo I'm
Maria Bartiromo and this is the Fox News
rundown
[Music]
Friday March 20th 2020
I'm Jessica Rosenthal FEMA is now in
charge of the federal response to the
virus that is supposed to help
streamline things but a former FEMA
director says even at this stage we've
learned some hard lessons from our
response so far we've got to go back and
help citizens understand that they are
the true first responder for anything
that they face whether it's an active
shooter event whether it's a cyber crime
whether it's a hurricane or whether it
is the virus I'm Dave Anthony while
Senators try to work out a new way to
help Americans hit hard financially by
the coronavirus we talked to one who has
to work from home under self quarantine
I am about a block away from the Capitol
I can see the Capitol dome from my
window but I am the quarantines confined
to my 300 square foot palatial studio
and I'm Jimmy Fallon I've got the final
word on the Fox News rundown
[Music]
FEMA the Federal Emergency Management
Agency is now in charge of the US
response to the Cova 19 virus the FEMA
now is fully engaged at the highest
levels today FEMA is activated in every
region we are at level one level one
being the highest level President Trump
talked to the state's governor's at FEMA
headquarters as the agency took the
reins governor's like Louisiana's John
bel Edwards response yeah we're going to
speak to the VA with recipient immediate
at least as a switch but we'll get that
approved for you one way or the other
Wow there is testing underway on a
vaccine more immediate help may be on
the way President Trump says they're
reviewing drugs that other countries are
using and are looking at drugs already
approved for other uses like malaria for
use in fighting this virus specifically
chloroquine but the nice part is it's
been around for a long time so we know
that if it if things don't go as planned
it's not going to kill anybody the FDA
says that drug along with others like
REM de severe still need further
clinical study vice president Mike Pence
said certain medical gear and equipment
is being ramped up courtesy of companies
like Honeywell and 3m those companies
have now greatly increased by the tens
of millions their production of
so-called n95 maps that will give our
healthcare workers the protection that
they need he says they have liability
protection now and can sell directly to
hospitals a House and Senate approved
package signed by the president provides
things like freak Ovid 19 testing and
expanded unemployment insurance
lawmakers were next working on a
financial aid package to give families
money directly dr. deborah birx says
testing has increased dramatically and
shows stricter isolation and containment
measures are needed depending on where
cases are over 50 percent of the cases
come from three states
this is why we continue to prioritize
testing in those states in addition 50%
of the cases come from ten counties when
it comes to what those states and
counties need FEMA is in charge of
getting resources to them so basically
FEMA is the only agency in the country
that has the ability to manage incident
command for an event of this magnitude
brach long is the chairman at Haggerty
consulting and the former head of FEMA
what what happened as a result of the
FEMA going to a level one is referring
to their National Response Coordination
Center this is nothing unique we went to
level one activity all the time in 2017
and 18 when the when the agency was
helping to lead the nation through the
crisis of Harvey Irma Maria you know the
California wildfires Florence you know
all the other hurricanes they hit and so
what you're seeing is is that there
needs to be a clear consistent chain of
command to help process resource
requests from governor's across all 50
states and tribal territories and island
territories as well okay interesting I
was gonna say what exactly is FEMA doing
when they when they do that and they're
there helping people get what they need
depending on what's needed in each
different state and region absolutely so
HHS while HHS and CDC are still in
charge they're the technical experts of
this of this event they understand the
virus they understand the epidemic D me
ology all of those aspects but what FEMA
does is helps the nation understand
total asset visibility for example you
know how much supplies we have they also
have the ability to track resource
requests coming up from the local
governments to the state governments
ultimately to the federal level and the
way this works is that disasters even
this one you know for the virus support
is federally supported state management
locally executed and so when a local
governments capability has been exceeded
they call upon the state when a state
governors a capability has been exceeded
they call upon FEMA and in this case you
know they're trying to track resource
requests they don't have an unlimited
amount of resources and they have to
prowl
our ties these resource requests but
eventually they activate contracts they
give these resource requests to the to
the appropriate agency that can fulfill
it and then they push it down through
the pipe through a governor ultimately
to the ground level and in local
communities so let's talk about supplies
for a minute because I mean that seems
to be a huge part of this story
obviously when when you're at female for
example were you aware of how many and
ninety-five masks you know could be made
and where they could be made or how many
ventilators we as a country had even in
that national stockpile I imagine FEMA
was very well-versed on what what
exactly we had did you ever think to
push from for more such be roarsome n't
absolutely and here's here's what FEMA
did about it and this is what we did
under my leadership is we created what
are called community lifeline concepts
it is now doctrine within FEMA and the
nation's got to realize this that the
infrastructure that we depend on on a
daily basis is largely owned by the
private sector the you know the federal
government really has no control over
the a lot of the infrastructure and so
we went to the community lifelines
concept to say hey what are the
indispensable services that have to be
maintained in any community that if
they're not maintained people die our
life routine is disrupted and we
rethought our plans on how we needed to
get the private sector industry to the
forefront of helping us overcome
disasters and prepare for disasters
understanding the supply chains the
vulnerabilities and rewriting and
rethinking concepts to make sure that
we're attacking disasters correctly like
this one Rock when when you were part of
when you were head of FEMA how much did
it bother you that that China was in
charge of manufacturing so much of our
medical supply gear and equipment I mean
did that strike you as problematic
absolutely we need a by American
campaign again and to create you know
American independence for our public
health mechanisms I mean we grow a lot
of cotton in this country for example
but we produce a very small volume of
gauze pads or surgical aprons and we
have got to reduce our vulnerability
and in control our own destiny away from
these other country you know countries
and I think that's the biggest lesson
learned that it's got to overcome the
other biggest lesson learned is the lack
of business continuity plans in this
country within our private sector and
particularly the small business a lot of
businesses are being impacted
financially obviously and this is going
to be a tough financial time for the
weeks and months to come but we've got
to instill business continuity plans in
all businesses - you know and business
interruption insurance you know for
these companies in the future to help
bolster and their capability to be able
to go through these disasters as well
you were once head of FEMA when you saw
people buying toilet paper and bottled
water and long lines at grocery stores
what did you think other than gosh I'm
glad I'm not in charge of FEMA right now
you know we do not have a true culture
of preparedness in this country and I
say it over and over again and when I
was in office the goal the first goal
there were three goals that we
implemented at FEMA the very first one
was create a true culture of
preparedness in this country it doesn't
exist and panic ensues because people
are not prepared and you know the thing
about it is is that we've got to go back
and help citizens understand that they
are the true first responder for
anything that they face whether it's an
active shooter event whether it's a
cyber crime whether it's a hurricane or
whether it is the virus so we have to
give people tangible skills again we've
got to go back and teach people how CPR
is done properly we've got to teach
people how to mitigate their homes
protect their businesses with insurance
or protect you to mitigate their
businesses you know bolster their supply
chains and their vendors how do they
meet their mission essential critical
functions when they can't access their
building when they've lost a certain
percentage of their staff when they have
lost access to resources we've got to go
back in and implement that and the other
thing is that's really killing us as a
country is what is known as asset
poverty too many Americans are highly
leveraged they do not have three to six
months worth of savings that they can
put their hands on and we've got to go
back and teach our kids and change our
education system to focus on financial
resiliency teaching people how money
works how to budget properly how to save
how to retire
but right now in this country we teach
kids that the SAT score is the most
important score in their life when it's
actually going to be their credit score
and we need to revamp rethink everything
that we do when it comes to giving
people baseline education in this
country it sounds like the CDC and the
FDA and maybe some others messed up in
the in the early stages here right with
testing and put us a few weeks behind at
least as an emergency manager and
consultant and executive how important
in your mind would it have been to have
that information even if it meant a lot
of us you know tested positive to have
that information earlier on well a
couple a couple things you know forget
the test for a minute you know every
American right now needs to you know
needs to act as if the virus is in their
community and heed the warnings if every
American does that and we do what the
president is asking us to do for the
next 15 days then the impacts will be
reduced
forget the test you know the next thing
is is that you know we got to realize
that this is a virus we've never dealt
with it's not like we can create these
tests out of thin air there's a lot of
science and and you know medical
practice that has to go into creating
the right test and then you've got to
mass-produce it and then you have to
implement plans to disseminate the test
and so you know the federal government
is you know I truly believe they are
trying to work as fast as they can to
not only create the test mass-produce
the test and put it out there but people
have got to back up and realize this
isn't you know we've never seen this
virus before so the tests didn't exist
the next thing that countries had it
though other countries seem to have it
and tests a lot of people much more
quickly I mean look at South Korea they
would they had you know so many more
tests going didn't they you know I don't
know I can't verify what what was being
done and you know the other countries
but when it comes to our country I know
that you know this is not something that
we had readily available as tests now
will the system need to be rethought
when it comes to how do we quickly
create create a mass-produced test what
was getting in the way of us being able
to do that from walls you know you know
are there things that we could have done
for for waivers from the FDA to speed up
the process you know that's all well and
good but I I go back to the culture
preparedness the greatest thing that
needs to be done right now as citizens
need to be taking two separate
and tactics that have been put into
place by the president seriously
finally brock last question I've seen
varying degrees of reaction ah you know
my social media feed and in my personal
life with my friends and family there
are some who say this is ridiculous
we've gone way over the top the economy
is really suffering we you know it the
flu is way worse and I've seen on the
other end you know people say we don't
know what this virus can do look at
Italy we need to be safe we need to
hunker down is the answer somewhere in
the middle or is it just it has it been
over height so what's the right balance
well you know the question that I get as
being a former FEMA administrator is
what kept you up at night and a lot of
people would ask me that what what
really worried me the most and my answer
was always a pandemic event we don't
have great experience with it there's a
lot of unknowns and it really is going
to depend on how quickly and how well
community mitigation tactics or
separation tactics are implemented and
you know if the president had gone into
the minute that we had learned about
Wuhan and China and lock down the whole
country he would have been ridiculed
from the moment of overreacting you know
and so you know the problem is is that
now I think they're trying to strike the
right balance of we've got to reduce the
spread flatten the curve they're also
taking tremendous action to protect the
economy but I got to tell you public
health events scare me more than
anything
as a former FEMA administrator and I
appreciate the activities that are being
put forward by the federal government at
this point and a state and local a
former head of FEMA Brock long thank you
so much for your time thank you it's a
pleasure
[Music]
this is Jimmy fella with your Fox News
commentary coming up a lot of Americans
are stuck working at home during this
coronavirus outbreak amid all the
offices in the schools and stores and
other businesses closed forcing people
who can still work to do it remotely and
we caught up with a u.s. senator who's
in the same boat I'm about a block away
from the Capitol I can see the Capitol
dome from my window but I am quarantined
to confined to my 300 square foot
palatial studio senator Cory Gardner is
a Republican from Colorado who's not at
his office as a precaution on her self
quarantine you know I'm sure there are
some that may have a little bit better
abode but when I get the family here I
hop from the bed to the couch to the
cotton out the door so you have a small
place to be for what the next two weeks
know you know so I am quarantined for 14
days now that 14-day period started with
the last contact I had with the person
who sort of triggered the quarantine so
so Wednesday the 25th is when I am
quarantined through
should I not develop any symptoms or
conditions and at this point I'm a
hundred percent to find no symptoms no
conditions okay you felt nothing just
felt normal the whole time normal the
whole time as normal as normal as I can
be alright so how did you find out that
this happened yeah it's a great question
so and I'm assuming there are thousands
and thousands of people across the
country that are having these same
conversations it was around 4:00 or 5:00
in the afternoon I get a phone call from
the the the Tri County Health Department
and this was I guess on Tuesday
afternoon the Tri County Health
Department that said I had a meeting
with a constituent in my office that had
been showing symptoms while he was in
the office and it was a personal meeting
you know you know in in in my official
office that was a sufficient concern to
them that they said you need to be
quarantined and so that's how I found
out was that Tuesday afternoon phone
call from Tri County Health which is
sort of it covers three counties in the
Denver suburban area but that that
meeting was last week right that meeting
was last week that's correct
and so you know that was you know on the
11th of March so 14 days from the 11th
of March we're when you met with this
person did you notice that they might
not be feeling well you know we met with
so many people that day i i don't recall
meeting with anybody who seemed that
they were coughing sneezing feverish
sweating right huh everybody looked fine
but we did meet with a lot of people i
know that one of my colorado
counterparts who also met with somebody
on the 11th of march same day I did is
quarantined as well so I'm assuming this
group met with multiple people in the
delegation right is that Congressman
Jason crow is that right yes correct all
right have you have you have you spoken
to congressman crow as you both are self
quarantined he's back home in Colorado
so at least he's at home I got you know
sentenced here in Washington but I did
text him and asked him what kind of
ramen noodles he was having so tell me
it has to be hard to be away from the
action you say you can see the dome it
can't be there there is a lot going on
is it frustrating you know it's
frustrating that I can't be there to
vote obviously but I am very much
participating in every negotiation
that's taking place I just got off the
phone with the Secretary of the Treasury
to talk about concerns over IRAs and
401ks as well as restaurant hotel needs
right now and what we were gonna what
this third phase package would look like
I expressed some concerns of to my
banking committee colleagues in the
Senate about guidances on troubled debt
restructuring our banks want to help but
they're concerned they're gonna get
nailed by the regulators and penalized
by the regulator's if they help so we're
trying to get additional guidance as to
them so even though it's only a couple
hours into the workday here we've
already burned up the phone lines and
had to recharge my phone yeah I know
there is a lot of an effort to help
small businesses and companies that have
been hit hard obviously been forced
essentially by the government to shut
down to close but as far as helping
Americans this idea of a check or two
that would go out how do you feel about
that well look there there are many ways
to do this I had suggested early on that
we
work through the unemployment insurance
process to create a new category of
workers wouldn't require them to be laid
off it would not require them to be
fired but it would be a way to get
assistance through an existing mechanism
quickly you know maybe that's the way it
goes maybe there is a assistance direct
benefit in the form of a check it can't
take six months it can't take a year
it's got to happen soon we do need to
have have immediate relief look this is
different than ten years ago when you
had bad actors doing bad things asking
for a bailout this this is a virus that
came out of the blue out of China and
here we are today dealing with it and
it's not a Democrat or Republican or a
business creation and that's why we have
to deal with this and we have to deal
with it in a way thank goodness our
economy is as strong today as it was
going into this because we're gonna need
every ounce of that strength that once
we get out of this now as far as those
checks are concerned the reason I keep
focusing on it is because everybody
wants to know if they're gonna get one
and be how much it's gonna be now when
you deal with this I know that they want
to have some means testing in the sense
that yeah based based on income I don't
know what levels you want but you know
people who live in big cities or in
suburbs of big cities a family of that
has two working parents and maybe two or
three kids they might have a hundred
fifty thousand or two hundred thousand
dollars in income and it's possible that
both of them aren't working or are
having a lot less money come in and they
wouldn't get checks if you cap it at a
hundred or a hundred and fifty thousand
so how do you decide who should and
shouldn't get the money well that's it
that's one of the reasons why I thought
going through an existing scalable
mechanism like unemployment insurance
would be a better approach because you
could make those kinds of anomalies into
account when you did the funding for it
so so that's being negotiated right now
because you're right $1,000 in Manhattan
is different than $1,000 in Burlington
Colorado sure and so there are multiple
ways that we could have done this you
know the most important thing is getting
it done quickly and out the door
effectively and how is it that two
parties who
impeachment drama and hadn't they're at
each other's throats for the last three
years of the Trump administration how
are you actually able to work together
well we just have to get you have to put
all that aside you have to I mean there
this is not a time for a sort of
political point-scoring this is not a
time to take your your pet project that
you've been trying to get done for years
to now use this crisis as a moment to
score a victory this is all hands on
deck if I could find a word that was
more urgent than the word urgent I would
I understand I do but it fascinates me
to think that that Nancy Pelosi the
House speaker and President Trump could
sit in the same room and work together
because it was so nasty between the two
well you know our parents taught us to
turn the other cheek and we have to do
that and more at this time and it is a
challenge you know I remember it did
back going back to impeachment in
January when the first sort of word of
coronavirus was starting to leak out and
we know that it was starting to spread I
I had said we need a hearing and we need
a hearing now and we ought to delay this
start of this day of I think it was the
the last day of the closing arguments of
the house I think so right around
January 24th I think it would be and I
said look we added all of us every
single senator ought to be in a
closed-door briefing with CDC NIH FDA
about this new virus and we should do it
now instead of doing that we got a
briefing we're like 10 of us showed up
or maybe fewer but everybody was focused
on the Pietschmann and what a shame now
there are others in Congress who are
also not at the Capitol Congressman
Mario diaz-balart a Republican from
Florida and ben mcadams a House Democrat
from Utah were the first two lawmakers
to become coronavirus patients testing
positive now McAdams has described a
fever and coughing and labored breathing
as he deals with his infection and Diez
boulaert says he's feeling better House
GOP Whip Steve Scalise was in
attacked with his Republican colleagues
so like Senator Gardner he's staying
home as a precaution I'm feeling fine
and you know just out of an abundance of
caution self with being with Mario last
week last Friday we were meeting on a
number of things but you know just felt
like the best thing to do would be to
self quarantine right now through the
period talked to the attending physician
at the house and that's what he
suggested to no congressman Scalise told
Fox Business Network Maria Bartiromo
I've been on a lot of conference calls
of course still dealing with so many
different items that were working on so
what happens if there is a huge spike of
coronavirus cases and a lot of lawmakers
are infected I asked that to Senator
Gardner it's it's really amazing because
the day that I was quarantined I asked
my staff to get me a report on what can
be done procedurally how the steps work
that require 60 votes that require 51
votes or just require a majority of
members present because you know there
are certain things if somebody objects
that are gonna take 60 votes to overcome
there are certain things that require a
certain number of votes and I this is
something we have to look at long term
because we don't have a remote voting
system you know we can't do this
the way maybe we ought to look at in the
future because whether it's a pandemic
or so you know we've had rice and
attacks at the Capitol and anthrax
attacks over the years this is certainly
different and that's why I think we need
to be thinking about this because we've
had a corona virus emerge you know very
rapidly over the last decade the
different kind of novel virus and it
doesn't look like that's gonna stop for
the time being all right now back to you
and your self quarantine
what are you doing how are you getting
your food do you have all the toilet
paper you need well my if I didn't have
all the toilet paper I'd eat it
apparently I wouldn't be able to get any
more so so you know I had I'm not
allergic to anything back home in
Colorado but I find myself allergic to
Washington which is probably a good
thing though I had to have somebody drop
off some flonase at the office
at the door today so they just came over
dropping off knocked on the door and ran
away and you know so so that's the kind
of thing we're doing I had you know
enough ramen I think to feed a for a
couple months here so I should be okay
but that gets old
nothing yes you know look I laugh about
it but there are people who are in very
very serious dire need and I had talked
to my office about making sure that we
send out this message to people
check your neighbor call your neighbor
see how they're doing see if they need
help see if they need groceries people
that you've talked to people that you
haven't talked to just reach out call
them you know text them find them on
Facebook just to make sure that
everybody is okay because we're going to
get through this we're going to be
stronger than ever we're going to unite
as a country use this opportunity to
make connections that maybe we've
misfired on over the last several years
well I hope that it's uh it's over for
you like it's supposed to be next week
and you can get back to it well thank
you I my my place has never been as
clean as it is now I'll say that Senator
Cory Gardner thank you very much for
joining us
hey thanks for having me
it's the Perino and steyr Walt I'll tell
you what podcast Dana Perino of the five
and Fox News political editor Chris
Stein wall dissect the ins and outs of
national politics subscribe and listen
now by going to fox news podcasts
dot-com and now some good news with
Tonya J powers social distancing to help
contain the corona virus means people
worldwide are coming up with creative
ways to connect with each other while
staying physically apart one man in
Boston is doing just that
Mike DeCarlo reworked the words to the
Neil Diamond hit Sweet Caroline a
favorite among Boston Red Sox fans it
now reflects a more coronavirus esque
lyric
every night at six o'clock DeCarlo takes
to his apartment window in Back Bay to
sing it to the neighborhood now others
have started to join in for the corn
tunes
[Music]
[Applause]
just one way people are bringing a
little good news to their part of the
world
Tonya J powers Fox News
[Music]
it's time for your Fox News commentary
what's on your mind the NBA season has
been suspended in an effort to stop the
corona virus it's terrible news for the
sports community unless you happen to be
a Knicks fan like me in which case it
comes as sweet relief but with every
major North American sports league
suspending play comes an opportunity for
all of us to compete in the ultimate
team sport
stopping the coronavirus this is
certainly not the championship matchup
we were hoping for heading into March
Madness but as they always say in sports
you have to play the teams on the
schedule and team Corona has no shot
against us if everybody on Team humanity
does their job sure you can't hit a
buzzer beater but you can stop beating
up your political opponents on Twitter
we're facing a global pandemic folks now
it's not a time to be a Republican or a
Democrat it's time to be an American
team humanity needs a unified locker
room and that can't happen if we're
getting called for technical fouls on
social media so when you're done
cleaning up your act be sure to wipe
down your smartphone
because the only thing filthier than the
language on Twitter are the touch
screens we're typing on staying calm
with the game on the line is one of the
biggest challenges we face right now
there's a lot of hysteria surrounding
our opponent most of which is fueled by
misinformation online if you're going to
pass an update to one of your teammates
be sure it's from a trusted government
agency like the CDC if the health tip is
coming from a guy who's holding a beer
in his profile picture make like the
Beatles and let it be you also need to
know that our team has a very deep bench
so there's no need to show up to work if
you're feeling sick
get some rest watch some Netflix heck
you can even dress up as a mummy with
all that toilet paper you hoard it but
by all means if you're under the weather
make it a home game and lastly be sure
to wash your hands everywhere you go and
stay at least six feet away from people
at all times not only will it help you
avoid Corona but nobody likes a close
talker so don't be that guy or gal or
mommy if you went with my previous
suggestion look team this is quite
literally the fight of our lives but if
everybody goes out there and plays the
type of game we're capable of there's no
doubt in my mind we're gonna take home
the championship now on the count of
three let's bump elbows and go out there
and win this thing check out Fox across
America with me Jimmy fella weekdays
from noon to 3 on Fox News Radio comm
and Fox Nation
you have been listening to the FoxNews
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
the Fox News radios power Li newscast at
FoxNews podcasts dot-com and for
up-to-the-minute news visit Fox news.com
[Music]
love FoxNews click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the FoxNews rundown
playlist for the latest episodes